hi I'm Bob Forbes with Forbes and I'd
like to answer the question from a
litter please tell us what you care
about what future direction you see how
you will contribute to improving the
state of the world what's fun about
being here Davos is the chance to meet
with a lot of people connect with them
exchange ideas and I've come away with
something called optimism there's far
more here than people with tend to find
sometimes but my contribution i hope
will be to take this sense of optimism
the sense of community and connection
and bring it to not just my work but
also my writing and I hope the world
will be a better place for that that